gravity is definitely one of the movies
I like to refer to as a I am never going
to do that type of movie it's the movie
that ensures that I will never do
whatever it is showing as an occupation
I will never be an astronaut that is
never gonna happen
[Music]
gravity is directed by Alfonso Curran
probably said that absolutely
incorrectly but what can I say I'm not
from his country I don't know how to
pronounce his name I apologize I'm
American and I'm stupid and it stars
Sandra Bullock and George Clooney as two
astronauts who are doing some repairs to
a satellite who encounters some horrific
debris that causes everything to go
completely wrong and now they're falling
off structure they're floating in space
they're trying to get to another
satellite so they can hopefully launch
home and this entire 90-minute movie is
essentially about a struggle to try to
get out of space and into earth this
movie has some of the best special
effects I have ever seen ever the
opening shot is an incredible blend of
CGI to be able to make it look like this
incredible one-take wonder that just
blew my mind this is a movie that is a
strict thriller I mean this is a thrill
ride of a movie from start to finish it
is so well directed this movie looks
beautiful the CGI is absolutely stunning
it was completely convincing the 3d is
also very impressive you just really
felt as if Sandra Bullock and George
Clooney are up there floating around and
you're with them there are so few takes
in this movie very long takes of people
floating around the camera pans around
large structures and the people are you
know interacting with it it's very very
visually stunning one of the best parts
of this movie is also a real perspective
as if you are there you really feel as
if you are in that suit sometimes
there's even a lot of first-person shots
where you can see like Sandra Bullock's
hands trying to climb up a rope or
something
and you really feel as if you are in
that suit having a hard time breathing
and there are parts of the movie that
actually gave me that weird stomach
feeling like you're kind of losing
gravity when you go over a large Hill in
your car and you get that one little
second of no gravity where your stomach
kind of lurches up a lot of moments like
that in this movie where I was just like
oh grab onto something hurry up grab
onto something just grab on it
Sandra Bullock is really terrific in
this movie this is definitely a good
showcase for her acting because she
seems to be the one who's always in the
most trouble in this movie out of the
two characters and she did a really good
job I would say Flutie didn't have quite
as much to do in this movie simply
because he is that guy that's always
like I'm gonna keep my cool right now he
was the guy there to always keep saundra
Bullock cool because she was the one who
was more fearful and more nervous and
seemingly always in more danger so he
didn't have as much to do as a character
he didn't learn as much about him as a
character Sandra Bullock is the
character that gets the most attention
in this movie the most back story and so
you care most about her in this movie
which is obviously their goal it's not
like they didn't give Clooney enough
stuff to work with
they were definitely more focused on
Bullock as a character and she did a
great job in this movie there's also
some interesting themes in this movie
that are largely told through imagery
and visuals that you kind of don't
necessarily pick up on if you're just
watching the movie and thinking oh it's
honor Bullock's flitting around and hope
she makes it back there's a lot of there
are a lot of different underlying themes
in this movie for sure and if you're a
discerning viewer I think you'll pick up
on it my only real issue with the movie
is that there are times where the movie
tries to be more emotional than I think
the script warrants because this is a
straight-up thriller okay it's not
science fiction this is very realistic
in space they have all the various
things and I'm sure they did a ton of
research to get certain things correct
you really just feel like these are two
people trying to struggle to survive and
that aspect of the movie is brilliant I
think whenever the screenplay tries to
get into a more emotional character
building moment that it falters a bit
because there's no time for that really
in the movie there's not much time for
character build-up and so it's a little
hard to feel that close to the
characters you're really just like wow I
feel like I'm there right now and that's
kind of what makes you feel close to it
gravity is an intense movie that I
really enjoyed I'm gonna give it an a -
I think that it is a special-effects
masterwork that you should definitely
check out in theaters and hopefully
enjoy so guys thanks very much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]